- The biggest beef
I have with him,
or really the biggest beef,
is over natural immunity.
His pushing to force
children to be vaccinated
is based on his assumption
that natural immunity
doesn't count.
And when you ask them about it,
as CNN asked him once in
the last month, they said,
what about natural immunity?
He says, oh, that would
be interesting. Wow.
We should look into that,
as if the subject had
never crossed his mind,
but that's just one more
lie in a list of lies.
(jazzy music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is Anthony Fauci's
worst nightmare,
as well as the senator from
the great state of Kentucky.
Senator Rand Paul, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me.
Glad to be with you.
- I know we're
tight on time here,
so we're only going to
knock out two topics.
We're going to talk
Fauci and inflation.
Everyone's seen some of the
brouhahas between you guys.
Where are you at with
Fauci and mandates
and trust in science and
all of it at this point?
- Well, I think the
biggest problem is that
he has a casual disregard
for individual liberty,
but he also has a
casual disregard for
the science, as well.
You add those together,
and it's sort of a recipe
for authoritarianism,
and that's basically what he is,
is an authoritarian.
So, lately, the biggest
beef I have with him,
or really the biggest beef,
is over natural immunity.
His pushing to force
children to be vaccinated
is based on his assumption
that natural immunity
doesn't count.
And when you ask him about it,
as CNN asked him once in
the last month, they said,
what about natural immunity?
He says, oh, that would
be interesting. Wow.
We should look into that,
as if the subject had
never crossed his mind,
but that's just one more
lie in a list of lies.
He obviously knows
about natural immunity.
In fact, when they
do the studies on
children for vaccines,
they exclude children
who've already had COVID.
That's why we don't know
whether it's safe for kids
who have already had COVID,
because they're
not in the studies.
Why does he exclude
them from the studies?
Because they've got
natural immunity,
and they would
confound the study.
So, he's dishonest
at every level.
So, between natural immunity,
the origins of the virus,
the mask wearing, at
every step of the way,
I think he's been
dishonest to people,
mainly because he believes
in the bigger truth,
the collective truth.
He believes that it's
okay to lie to the people
because the people are ignorant
and need to be told what to do
by an authority like himself.
And basically, that's a
recipe for authoritarianism.
- So, as more and
more of the stuff
that you've been talking
about for a year with Fauci
comes out, do you think
he will ever pay a price
politically or have to
step down or anything?
I mean, I think one of the
reasons people are so frustrated
is they see that these
people lie constantly.
They get caught in the lies,
and nothing ever
happens to them.
- Well, the interesting
thing is history.
His name is
tarnished in history,
and his reputation is tarnished.
I would say his
reputation is in tatters.
Now, the left-wing
media still likes him
and treats him with kid gloves.
But if you actually
look at the numbers,
probably when he first came
out in March of that year,
and he sounded like a
reasonable scientist,
probably 95% of
people trusted him.
We've polled it in our state.
Less than half the
people trust him.
Less than half of
people in Kentucky
actually trust what
he's saying so that,
he's come down quite a bit here.
He's still a menace, though.
He's still a menace to
individual liberty every day,
because if you've seen,
he even gets out in front of
the Biden Administration now
saying, well, I don't know
what they're going to do,
but I would ban travel.
But see, none of it's
based on science,
because now we know that
those who have been vaccinated
can catch it and
can transmit it.
So to punish the unvaccinated
because somehow
they're the danger
when everybody's at
risk for this, frankly.
Everybody's at risk
for catching it.
for passing it.
But frankly, only certain
segments of the population
are at risk for
being hospitalized
and dying from this.
For the most part, those who
are younger are not at risk.
And one of the biggest things
I've been pushing
back with lately
is that the whole country of
Sweden, 1.8 million children,
have not worn masks at
all in the last year,
zero deaths, and among teachers,
the same amount of illnesses
as the rest of the public.
So no increased illness for
teachers and zero deaths
among children wearing no masks.
Why don't we look
at the science?
- How elated were you when
we got this court order
that the mandate
for companies with,
was it 100 or 1000 employees?
I think 100 employees?
- 100 employees, yep.
- That this is basically
on pause, at least for now,
partly because of a lawsuit
involving the Daily Wire
led by my friend
Harmeet Dhillon.
I mean, we got some
good news this week.
It's rare, but we
got some good news.
- Absolutely, the Fifth
Circuit's put a stay on it,
which is important.
No one has to adhere to it.
When January 4th comes,
with the stay on it,
OSHA will not enforce it.
So, every small business
person listening to this,
you do not have to adhere to
it until the court rules again.
They've consolidated the cases,
and it's going to the Sixth
Circuit, which is in Cincinnati.
Has many Kentucky judges
that have been appointed
in recent years under
the Trump Administration,
by a Republican Congress.
We think that we will get a
fair hearing in the Sixth Court.
Our hope is that it goes all
the way to the Supreme Court,
and they nullify this thing.
The interesting irony of this is
it may be that the
Obamacare ruling
is the precedent for making
this unconstitutional.
You remember with Obamacare,
they said you can't force
people to buy insurance
under the Commerce Clause,
but then they twisted themselves
into a pretzel and said,
oh, you can do it under
the Taxation Clause.
OSHA and the mandate are
under the Commerce Clause.
So it may well be that
the precedent of saying
Obamacare was unconstitutional
under the Commerce Clause
may be why they strike
this vaccine mandate
as also being unconstitutional.
- So, one more thing on this,
and then we'll
move to inflation.
Are the courts sort of your
last hope at this point
that our executive branch,
obviously, right now is
completely out of control.
The legislative branch seems
either completely broken
or unable to really do
anything or completely ignored.
Are the courts the hope?
Is that what we should all
be pinning our hope on?
- This should show
people that danger
of handing the entire government
over to the Democrats,
because they've
got the presidency,
both houses of
Congress, and so, yeah,
our only hope is in the courts
or holding them off until 2022.
But I will say that people
shouldn't get discouraged.
Moral outrage on the
internet, on your program.
You don't ever get
outraged, do you?
Well, let's say
you do on occasion.
- Once in a blue moon.
- But the thing is,
is moral outrage is having
some influence on Democrats.
When people got really
angry about people
looking at their check
accounts of $600 went through,
guess what?
They pulled that from the bill.
People right now are hopping mad
about $450,000 being given
to immigrant families
that came across
and were separated.
People think that's insane.
And my guess is they will
eventually pull back on that.
On the mandate, well,
opinions are mixed in
the country on vaccines.
On mandating it and
taking someone's job
if they don't adhere
to the mandate,
only 14% of America
supports that.
So, we're getting
ready to have a vote.
We're forcing, it's
called a privilege to vote
on repealing this
law in Congress.
We've got all 50
Republicans in the Senate
to sign onto it now.
So what's going to happen is
there's going to be
a lot of outrage.
I mean, the biggest economic
damage from this rule
will happen in West Virginia.
We had an economist
crunch the numbers,
and because West Virginia
has a high number
of unvaccinated folks
and a high number of
employers that have over 100,
they will be economically
hurt worse than any country,
any other state in the union.
Maybe that'll influence.
If we get another Democrat,
we then defeat the regulation.
Unfortunately, Biden will
veto it, but it'll look awful
if the majority of Congress
actually votes to veto his rule,
and then he has to overrule it.
- All right, so let's
shift to inflation
for the remaining time.
You know, if you listen
to Jen Psaki and Joe Biden
and Pete Buttigieg, the reason
that we can't get things,
you know, in stores and that
everything is slow right now,
and it takes six
months to get a couch
and money doesn't
seem to have the value
is because we're all
buying so much stuff
that they just can't
make it fast enough.
That seems to be the meme
that they're putting out.
I sense you don't
agree with that meme.
- Well, I'm afraid
this is an indictment
of our school system.
These people have complete
and utter ignorance.
- Yeah.
- We borrowed nearly
$4 trillion last year,
and we have inflation
this year of 6%.
That's what it's
from, borrowing money,
and then the Federal
Reserve prints money,
more money in circulation,
bids prices up,
the money loses
its value per unit.
If there, there's no clearer
explanation than that.
There's no way they can,
but what is their response?
Oh, we need to
borrow more money.
It has nothing to do
with borrowing money.
So, this is a real problem,
but I don't think you can fool
all the people all the time.
Frankly, people go
to the grocery store,
and I think they are sensing
that there is some culpability,
if not complete culpability
with the Biden Administration.
So, we'll see what happens.
But I think people
are turning sour.
The victory in Virginia
and the near victory
in New Jersey,
this shows a wave of
discontent that is rising up,
and, you know, Biden basically
lied to the American people.
He was going to be a unifier.
He was going to be a moderate.
He was going to work
with Republicans.
They're pushing forward thing
for which there is no
Republican support,
zero Republican support.
So, I think what
you're going to find is
the electorate is going to
be very, very upset by 2022,
and there's going to
be a big reversal.
- Senator, I just want
to understand this,
and I've got pen and paper here.
Are you telling me that 3.5
trillion does not equal zero?
- There was a little bit of
problem with the math there.
I've heard of new math,
and I know in California,
they add up things
differently, but, yeah,
3.5 trillion is 3.5 trillion.
That's what it'll cost.
And if they take that
money out of the economy
through taxes,
that's 3.5 trillion that
was being used usefully
and voted on by the consumer,
and you put it into
politicians' wishlist,
and it'll be used
less to effectively.
Or, if you borrow it,
you create inflation.
Either way, it's
not a good idea.
- And to tie it all together,
I'm fairly certain
that Anthony Fauci
is the highest paid person in
the federal government, right?
Over 420 grand, if
I'm not mistaken,
so, they're definitely
making some mistakes.
Senator -
- Yep, we're hoping to put
him into retirement soon.
We're gonna retire
him very soon.
- Absolutely. Senator,
always a pleasure.
You're welcome back anytime.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.